it was founded to bring the perpetrators
of the world's worst atrocities to
justice
more than 120 countries and states
accept the international criminal
court's authority
including palestine where the icc now
says it has the power to investigate
suspected war crimes
by the israeli military and armed
palestinian groups such as hamas
the decision was quickly and fiercely
rejected by
israel which isn't a member of the court
and doesn't recognize its jurisdiction
when the icc investigates israel for
fake war crimes
this is pure anti-semitism the court
established
to prevent atrocities like the nazi
holocaust against the jewish people
is now targeting the one state of the
jewish people
first it outrageously claims that when
jews live in our homeland
this is a war crime second it claims
that
when democratic israel defends itself
against terrorists
who murder our children rocket our
cities we're committing
another war crime the palestinian
authority and hamas
say the decision offers vital protection
for the palestinian people
with hamas insisting its military
activity is lawful
hamas and all residents groups are
engaged in a legal and legitimate battle
against a zionist occupation in
accordance with all international norms
and treaties that give us a right to
defend ourselves
before the israeli war arsenal that
kills indiscriminately
the palestinians want the icc to look
into israeli military operations in the
gaza strip in 2014
in which more than 2 000 palestinians
and 70 israelis were killed
also in the spotlight military tactics
used by israel against palestinian
protesters on the israeli-gaza border
and the construction of illegal
settlements in the occupied west bank
and east jerusalem icc top prosecutor
fatou bansuda
had previously called for investigations
saying there was a reasonable basis to
believe
war crimes had happened but progress
could be slow the courts only convicted
a handful of people in its 23-year
history
the pre-trial chamber said that there
might be a protracted process
um and the types of cases that we've
seen coming before the court
have gone on for years and years and
years and then
once we saw the word protracted that
kind of signified to us that although
we're now very much in the investigation
stage that there still could be
further delays and we'd be very very
concerned with that icc involvement in
the struggle between israelis and
palestinians
could shine a light on other state
injustices but what's less certain
is whether it will help or hinder the
troubled search for peace
in the middle east neve barker al
jazeera